metroids are very large they're one of
the largest animals in the ocean
certainly they're the largest of any of
the ray species
they can get up to about 25 feet across
when they come towards you and they're
that size they look like an alien
spacecraft as they go overhead
they actually blight out the sun
it's just so incredible to be that close
to such a large animal especially one
that you don't have to fear
[Music]
my name's andrea marshall i'm a manta
ray researcher and a marine biologist
i've been in love with the ocean all of
my life ever since i could remember i
wanted to be a marine biologist
when i moved out to africa with the
intention of studying things like great
white sharks
i actually shifted my focus over to
manta rays when i realized that no one
had ever done a study on mantras before
[Music]
one of the things that makes mantra so
special is that they're large and
sometimes people feel frightened by them
just because of their sheer size but
actually they're one of the most gentle
animals in the entire ocean
[Music]
manta rays are a very intelligent animal
they actually have the largest brain of
any marine fish but one of the things
that surprises me the most is just the
fact that they seek out encounters with
humans so this is an animal that swims
away from you this is an animal that
swims to you
they recognize you almost as a friend
[Music]
southern mozambique is just an
incredible location
i've lived here for the last 15 years
and even though i travel all over the
world to do my work i enjoy coming back
here because this is such a wild place
it's so exciting
[Music]
one of the reasons i began work on
manchester because i knew that these
animals were under threat recently you
know within the last 15 to 20 years they
have started to be fished for asian
tonics
and as a result of this we've seen manta
populations crashing across the globe
even here in mozambique where we don't
even have a very aggressive fishery
we've seen the population collapse by up
to about 98 over the last 15 years
we're starting to to lose them faster
than we can study them so it's really
important for me to get these messages
across to people who don't have the
opportunity to peek down into the
underwater world
you